all right robin i gotta cut
to where we are in the show where we
kind of left things off
the [ __ ] has finally aired
you want me too do you want me to yeah
hey
was that the first time you got to see
what had
happened other than when you were there
yeah and when i watched it my stomach
just
turned it just like brought back really
bad
memories i was so mortified i feel weird
kind of phrasing this way but it's like
you have the game tape now
where you could go back and watch
play-by-play of what happened
did you notice anything that you missed
in the moment to be honest
it was a little bit um not as bad as it
was
in the moment so i just remember being
in the moment and you know it's kind of
hard because it's really hard to see me
and what i'm doing but i'm holding up
the table
i actually ended up afterward having
like a strain on my shoulder and like
bruising on my arm from it
but i'm holding the tables on my mind
and i'm just like i feel helpless
because i can't do anything to stop it
and i'm just watching this go down and
i'm like
this is just awful and it's like don't
get me wrong like candace
can really irritate you like
i've been there with her but i held my
composure and i still
can't quite understand how it got to
that point like i don't understand why
they didn't really have an
honest heart-to-heart conversation like
all of this
could have been avoided if they just
would have communicated with one another
um and they were both being stubborn i
had no idea that monique had all this
you know frustration towards candice
this was all news to me watching the
show
um so when it happened i was just like i
don't know where this came from like i
really
i was at a loss for words and confused
so
i mean you know if there's a lesson to
be learned for anyone it's like
communication always helps uh prevent
stuff from like this from happening she
talks a lot
and doesn't know why people get pissed
off i can't i have to blame the money
for this
that's true yeah i blame her all the way
for this
you and gizet in the moment
blamed the moment on monique do you
still feel this that way having watched
it back
um i do just because we've all we've
been we've been on the show for five
years
there's been moments when we've all been
taken to a level where
you don't think you'll ever be i always
have in the back of my mind like i'm on
camera here
as a 40 year old woman with children
it's just not worth it to me so
it and yes like i said candace is
annoying but nothing she
said in that moment it wasn't like she
didn't say anything
that warranted someone to get very upset
and
looking back at it if this initial
contact wasn't made with the hair
the physical fight never would have
happened never
after monique was you know
in the hallway with the producer they
were separating everybody
candace started shouting and almost as
if she wanted the fight to continue
where she is
because you're a ghetto ass hood ass
[ __ ] i can't figure out
what her motion was there if she was
trying to process what happened
if she just wanted to let monique have
it do you know why she
started shouting i feel like when you
see stuff like that it makes it harder
for people
to feel sorry for candace in that moment
because it's almost like she was waiting
for monique to lose her cool
and monique lost her cool and candace
took the opportunity
to really like just make it worse
she probably was baiting her she
probably was trying to get her
to come out of her person and to lose
control
and in that moment candace won by by
making monique lose control i don't it's
it's it's unfortunate on both sides it
really is
it's so unfortunate i don't know if you
saw
but monique went on her instagram and
did a q a
and she pushed some blame so i did not
know until i actually watched the whole
altercation on video that
someone else pushed me i thought that
that was candace when she reached across
so i don't know if that was gisele or
robin but that was definitely a push on
my shoulder and that definitely
escalated
what's your reaction to that this is so
disappointing to me because
if i'm wrong i'm wrong like it's okay to
say
i lost control instead of trying to
place blame on other people
i'll be honest gizelle and i have been
harassed on social media blaming us for
this fight and it's just
it was very mind-boggling to me and it's
very disappointing
i don't understand all this like
shifting blame and trying to blame other
people for your actions because
what's the real story is it that you
thought candace threw a glass of wine at
you
or now you thought you felt candace push
you and i can honestly say i had a
bird's eye view because of where i was
standing
monique did this to her hair and candace
returned
favor returned served money cut on like
a vest and monique and candace just went
like this to her lapel
so she didn't come with any force but i
think once it got to that point where
where you know the ladies saw this
trading of
of contact across the table that's when
people are pulling candace and maybe
pushing monique away
and it happened so fast that i'm
i'm just disappointed that she would use
that as a reason
for coming across the table and grabbing
her hair and
doing what she did what we saw she did
it's like where does it end
where does it end if she would just say
i'm i'm so wrong
i don't you know i will never do this
again um you know please you know just
give me another chance or can we just
you know can we just start over i
i would be so open to that but hearing
the the shape the
the blame be shifted that's for me
worse than the actual fight we know the
next
episode is the group sit down
to talk out what happened when the glass
of wine went into my face
i remember reaching and then it was all
downhill from there that is an absolute
lie what can you tell me about what that
sit down looks like and what
comes from it um wow
it was a very open and honest and raw
conversation
um nobody held anything back and
we were you know just very um
hell bent on holding her accountable and
and figuring out
what's next and where do we go from here
there's a lot of
you know calling her out on some of the
stories that have been twisted
and saying look i want to live i want to
believe you but
on the last episode there was no remorse
at all not a drop of remorse but in this
meeting
there was some remorse and it definitely
was better that that
that happened without candace there i
mean that would have been a disaster
because the emotions are still running
really high for both of them
there is a bodyguard there or security
there whose idea was that and wasn't
necessary
okay so that was giselle giselle walked
in with that
security um and i thought it was a
little excessive
you know i'm i'm not scared of monique i
don't need to walk around with security
um so i thought that was giselle being
gisele being a little bit extra and
overboard
um but we find out actually karen also
had some
security there they were just kind of in
the background so
the giselle um the one that you do see
on camera is
um gisele's security
like i'm not scared
but then again i don't want to be this
is true
no you don't want to get involved but
totally tracks that they would be the
two to be
this is what we gotta do we gotta bring
in the big ones
there is a lot of speculation out there
that
that group meeting with monique is kind
of
the end of monique and the group we know
he is still a part of the show moving
forward but it seems like
she might not be part of the group
moving forward
um that speculation might be right
i did not see monique again after that
meeting i was never in a position where
i said
i never want to see her again um but
there's no way we can move forward as a
group with monique and candace in the
group
without the two of them at some point
coming to some sort
of i don't know place of forgiveness or
reconciliation
um and i can say right now that hasn't
happened does the group
have a similar conversation with candace
or what kind of conversations does the
group
have with candace about this to move
things forward
we really did not have like a sit down
with candace
as a group um
i think we talked to her a lot you know
individually
she also was the subject of a lot of
bullying
um on social media right after the fight
so
i just kind of wanted to be there for
her you know whether or not i thought
she was
responsible will we see cans take
ownership for
escalating that interaction
not really we never really during the
season
really thought that we needed to hold
canis accountable
because we've seen you know we've seen
candace say far worse things
so um we didn't think it was anything to
be
so upset about but watching it back i
can see where she's like a little
antagonistic
you brought up the reunion what do you
think this reunion is going to look like
do you think we're going to have
reconciliation do you
think forward movement can happen or
will it be a
thing where we kind of learn there's not
room in this group for both
candace and i pray
i really pray that we can all be
open and honest and really take
responsibility for everything and
listen to each other i'm just hoping
that um
i don't know like it'll be interesting
um
but i'm not confident i am hopeful
take not confident but hopeful all right
there's still a lot of season left to
watch
anything else you need to know about the
rest of season five
wow i mean as you can imagine just the
whole
fallout from the fight um you know that
that doesn't just like we don't
you know just have our one little
meeting and it goes away
like it carries over for the rest of the
season
um and it's pretty it's interesting to
see
how everyone handles it and
how it affects the dynamic of the group
i just i just pray i do pray that we can
all move forward because i think we are
a fantastic group of women we all bring
something to the show
we're all very unique in our own ways um
so
i i pray that we can all move forward
and
you know kiss and make up